um you're now drumming drumming I love
that your family must hate you I mean
that's the loudest thing ever
can I tell you so my wife calls me tappy
tappy tappy what you doing tapping
happen is you'll just subconsciously be
para dueling especially because if it's
like a new love like yeah it's so much
fun you know I took it up when I left
the show I knew that I would need
something to occupy my brain is not a
brain that does well with City downtown
yeah so if I have a lot of down time it
will it'll start out with like you've
had a really rewarding career and end up
with you failed everyone that ever loved
you like it goes there like almost you
know start here and then just like a day
by myself and it just goes I say so I
took this up about five years ago and a
buddy of mine was a drummer and so he
gives me lessons and I can die at first
I went on YouTube
because I really had always in my life
wanted to interact with music because I
feel like it's such a beautiful language
that I don't speak you know I'm not able
to how do you enjoy yeah and so I
thought to myself but I can definitely
bang on with sticks how hard could that
be not knowing that's really hard
drumming is hard I've tried yeah I
didn't know that I just thought it was
like yeah but it's really nuanced it's
really you know what it is when you're
so much of it is limb independence and
of all of these things and it might be a
very simple move but if your body is not
accustomed to that independence if you
really slow it down and you work on it
and then it starts to click yeah that
feeling you can almost feel like a new
synapse forming in your brain and it's
for you it's like the opposite of death
and I I swear to it it's keeping my
brain elastic yeah and you're right this
slowing down like any form of music
anyone eyes you know studies as a kid
like it's if you slow anything down it's
easier to learn it's just having the
patience like that's why I couldn't do
piano like vocals for some reason when I
started sight reading like with music I
picked it up really quickly but piano
I just couldn't play Beethoven like
right off the bat so I was like fine I'm
over it yeah I'm not doing it this isn't
my forte
I like the busy work of it like he'll
send just be like just to you know
sixteenth notes and just bang run but
you must have known that you were you
know I hate to use the phrase
predetermined but you must have felt an
affinity really early on because you
can't you can't walk around with a gift
like that and not realize it probably
pretty early on well I'm with you on
this until I was I mean I know thirteen
isn't old by any means but I just mean
all I don't know every time I hear
people an interview so like I've been
singing and dancing since I was two and
I'm like not me like I was like I I
literally you know everyone's saying in
my small town we all went to church so
everyone's saying I would have thought
for you even in a turn tomorrow or
something like that like even at eight
or nine years old you if you open your
mouth people are just gonna go not
really no not really I had certainly now
that said singers around me I really did
I and I've and I know people always say
like oh oh my god you think so any
conduced many things like I grew up with
a lot of girlfriends that could do that
so it wasn't really an abnormal thing
but you keep interviewing me Jon Stewart
quit interviewing me subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going